blog mas numero 7 abbiamo tre stamattina
mentre dormiva tranquillamente mi ha
chiamato chiedendomi di darle una mano
con il presepe
altri piani o ti può essere felice oggi
se no andiamo a dare una mano alla mia
madre in tutto questo luigi non è qui
con noi perché è andato a prendere dei
cornetti a portare la mia famiglia
se fossi andato da solo ha riportato
forse una manciata di polistirolo ma
fingere che sia stata una nostra idea in
una sua idea amore bravo che hai
comprato i pasticcini che sono la nostra
idea da portare i miei genitori in imola
e accede cascato così patron del
presidente coordinato pure questo è
stata una sorpresa
io lo chiamo dovere mettere a dieta
ancora gustativa si è così e così falso
lo vuoi la voi la colazione andava lui
la colazione la vuoi la colazione la poi
la colazione a voi giovani la colazione
da voi la colazione
ciao ciao
la colazione
l'azione la colazione e la colazione
insieme la colazione separa il terrore
sia motivo per cui vedete mia zia come
se fosse il super mario il primo
nintendo è perché mi ha espressamente
richiesto di non far vedere la faccia di
morte che aveva quella mattina a questo
dimostra come mia azienda non abbia mai
visto il mio fisico e come le facce di
morte siano ben accetta all'interno di
mio blog mas è il terrore sia quest'anno
col presepe
diciamo una cosa lei la vincitrice degli
ultimi anni del presepe migliore
possiamo dirlo senza però a lei
all'epoca tv faceva i migliori io penso
che ieri hanno eseguito che meglio sia
ti serve una mano per tuo presepe per
caso ma sta ritrattando è perché no in
cui non riesco a trovare se ti siamo qui
già da tre ore che ma che stai facendo
se ho qui da tre ore e ancora non siamo
riusciti a partire
stiamo per mangiare plastica in compenso
secondo te ce la facciamo ma come ha
fatto il presidente di damian e non lo
farò neanche quest'anno grazie per il
tuo sostegno a ma secondo te ce la
facciamo a farlo sì certo ma la mia
domanda è già facciamo a farlo in tre si
fino alle 7 di sera c'è quello che sta
gasatissimo pronto a divorarsi pastori
ti mettiamo delle ali da drago
diventerai il terrore di betlemme che
serve una mano
ci sono altre quattro scatena da quella
parte sapeva bene vado a farmi un caffè
cara la gamba maccarone eccolo pronto
caro caro guido curto e maggio gould o
il re magio conto sul pastore
guarda che porta ora incenso e mirra
mila crocchette ai questa specie di
copertina di un libro gigante che può
aprire me l'ha fatta fare su misura
apposta stefano valuto io vorrei delle
nostre faccio fare mentre loro lavorano
per il presepe guglielmo sull computer a
non fare niente
una cosa non è vero bugiardo qualcuno si
fotte
questo è un gruppo ma ma guarda la smith
image en esta twente ma poi c'è la
madonna quadro è notevole utilizzare per
il cielo questa coperta st coperta
ragazzi tutti quanti mezza trasparenti
nano nano mamma fammi vedere familiare
visto che insiste perché la insiste cioè
voluta una coperta al posto di del cielo
normale
ok ma bellissimo bellissimo ma possiamo
fare qualche altra piega cara dai non
essere geloso non essere johansson amato
un uomo come mi sento particolarmente
renzo piano andrò a prendere dei fogli
di giornale per fare le montagne vi
spiegherò a breve in che modo
non entrate su rai4 lorenzo non ci
faremo mai
hanno ragione loro forse il tenero con
le lucine dietro è più bella mostra
quello che mentre tu di scuola media
perché non te le vecchie e non sentirsi
al fungo nota del fuoco
mamma mia il fungo io ti vorrei
ricordare una cosa in questi ultimi anni
il tuo presepe a vedere montane così
squadrate che sembrava fatto su
minecraft ok cioè adesso che finalmente
è tornato all'ovile
il creatore di quelli che sono i presepi
del signore degli anelli me devi
insegnare che nel presepe ci va il
brecciolino però c'è una prima un
pavimento che di certo non siamo nello
spazio con la natività è che gli mette a
momento inizia a montare dei caschi da
stronati
adesso lo ha fatto l'era i fogli di
giornale si sa pallottola tema le devi
prima aprile perché non è non è aperto
so che non sai cosa voglia dire aprire
un giornale
intanto grazie a scotch spillatrice
stiamo creando questa specie di base di
montagne e adesso grazie stampelle
creeremo diciamo delle tensostrutture al
signor cannes all'opera spaccate mamma
usa questo modo abbiamo delle pinze
secondo sono sì che vado ad asciugare il
sudore a mia madre a ecco qua jean marc
è stato mandato da mia zia per spiare
perché se qua già mia mamma o no una
strazia che viene a spiare il nostro
presepe per vincere la competizione di
presepi ecco che c'è guido
quello che ci è caro
caro canon appunto che distrugge tutto
questo a questo cane stato no li vedete
come dice di due già mi chi ci sale
rischia la morte il ponte di suicidi
però per il resto si bisogna ci stiamo
dopo sto bruciando bisogna passare alle
luci ne comincerà a metterle sulla carta
in maniera strategica quindi all'interno
delle insenature dove sapete che
metterete delle casine perché perché le
luci che si vedono in mezzo al
presentano però non è che va in giro per
le strade per il day dei fasci di luce
delle lampadine buttate per terra non
sono credibili ragazzi ma cos'è le
coprite con new così con il muesli con
muschio scusate non ci vedevo chiaro e
poi come facciamo a levare il tuo video
da lì che parte questo morin ricordo
perché non parte il fatto anche una
puzza di sudore qua c'è gente che non si
lava gara
non so da quanto bello il cielo così
regalo così bello ma è molto meglio de
qua l'unica cosa che non penso che
vogliono riempire dovrà passare le luci
però commenti sono negativi no più che
altro del suo dando uno sprone velasco
raco voglio fare la ripresa per ogni
tipo compresi un drone non prende fuoco
da camera come prenderà forma e più non
col fuoco meno di una ripresa per e
adesso bisogna coprire con la roccia
la cosa importante quando si quando
milita i miei piace
pende la carta spiega ciarla che memore
anche del rischio detector aero
mammamia seri via devero sta studiando
solamente a venire lui ho capito ma
qualcosetta da schizzi che vende fisica
non sono stati forniti da vico ce
l'hanno con un'attesa questione
controfinta libro su mediamo e di carlo
ma da qui senti prima di andare io
voglio prendere questo è lo dividiamo
liberal mancini da parte della grecia
mammamia guarda
no quello no no no io però sto magnate
nulla è di ora è colpa tua
perché mi ha detto che era per me l'hai
detto per il connettore napoli 2 colpa
tua lui allora lo volevi tutto secondo i
piani
ieri gianni ti cedo il mio cornetto no
grazie
non ci scherzate para para
continua il lavoro su questo plastico
del sequel del signore degli anelli
mia madre regina delle montagne regina
del nord e di tutta quanta westeros
carisi mercati si cali devi vedere
almeno roccia non malice ma un realismo
vergognoso perdono così c'è da
vergognarsi e pero sicuramente non
uscire ma il realismo e quello
vergognoso e vergognoso perdonami è
vergognoso dire un caravaggio
intellettivo la luce li dobbiamo
trattare temi pali
allora come non detto allora se mettete
i fili in mezzo al vale anche utilizzare
il muschio a quanto pare la reggina
calissi ha detto che si può fare
[Musica]
in quanto mi piacciono i due piani
pazzesco questo si scopre abbiamo 100
euro 100 metri quadri del presepe
muschio un'altra schiena per me dove ci
stanno i buchetti questi qua delle
bombette che vi appoggiate sopra andate
e ci butta sopra il muschio nessuno ci
capisce più la fa a voi non potete
immaginare la fatica che abbiamo
impiegato nel fare un casting per tutti
quelli che sono i protagonisti di questo
presepe che manco la grande bellezza è
stato ingiustamente mandato di gesù il
navigato un sacco chi è guardia ma
bellissimo e naturale reale questi qui
questi qui questa signora che lava i
panni vi ricorda che ci vediamo sempre
domani alle 14 con un nuovo la mas è
bello pietro ciarlo armonia